it's professor kyle hendricks making his
third start of the season one up one
down with an era of 4.05
brady singer this is his 24th birthday
he is still looking for his first major
league win this is just his third major
league start he's got a tremendous
sinker and he pitches with conviction
brady working with salvador perez gets
the sign now the wind and pitch
slider swung on and missed struck him
out two outs baez is at first for kyle
schwarber
fastball by him so brady gets out of the
first inning strikes a pair out we head
to the second inning still looking for
our first run here is alberto monteci
two on nobody out
the pitch a swing a looper towards left
that's going to drop salvi will score
and the royals take the early
one-nothing lead nice job 2-0 here's
that change-up fading away that is how
you go to the opposite field look at
that call it a booty knock if you want
it don't matter that's called guiding
the ball out there where you want it to
be placed trust those hands and get them
on the board for singer here's jason
hayward long pause at the belt
and hayward drives it to deep right way
back there it's gone
and the cubs have the lead
well last night kb went deep for the
first time and tonight it's jason
hayward's turn home run number one a no
doubter man did he lean on this thing
middle and out over the plate and jay
does not miss it hayward hits this ball
a ton halfway up the bleachers in right
just like that cubs lead 2-1 here comes
the one-two
swing and a miss on a change-up that was
a beauty and he's got his first punch
out bring up three down for kyle
hendricks we go to the bottom of the
third inning the score of the cubs two
and the royals won javier baez their
shortstop rounded out his first time
going two on baez here comes and he
swings and misses at the fastball up and
that's the fourth strike out of the
night for brady singer so baez is the
strikeout victim and that'll bring up
schwarber schwarber waits singer gets
his sign from salvi here comes and a
swing and a miss he got him with a
slider down five strikeouts through
three innings for brady singer and he
has his first one two three inning of
the night 2-1 chicago jason kipnis
stocky left-handed batter with lots of
power
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the jason's getting it done here tonight
kipnissy's first two weeks his second of
the year and that was long gone
an absolute rocket to the seats in right
center kipnis waffles this ball this
ball is crunched line drive home run and
the cubs have hit two bombs in this game
and the cubs have a three-run lead the
royals have something cooking here
they've got the tying runs on with
nobody out here is solaire he is all for
two first pitch
he hits it high in the air left field
but playable for steven souza under it
makes the catch tagging is starling he
comes home jorge solaire he gets rbi
number four
and the royals have their second run
that's four to two eight strikeouts a
new career high for brady singer four to
two going to the sixth seventh inning
diving stop chris bryant up with it
out at first
that was just spectacular last night kb
was in left field david bodie was the
third base and bodhi made three really
good plays in kb sand not so fast young
man i can handle this hot corner by
myself this cub team
has really
improved on
every facet of the defensive side the
outfield defense the infield defense
everything and it's professor kyle
hendricks making his third start of the
season seven strong innings for kyle
hendricks it's his game to win trevor
rosenthal in all those years with the
cardinals this is his 20th career
appearance at wrigley field he's gone
four games he's not allowed an earned
run here's wilson contreras with one out
there's ribbon deep and it's gonna go
contreras wins the battle
cubs continue
to hit the ball out of the ballpark
that's number three tonight they've gone
deep in every game except for one this
year man was that the swings throughout
that sequence were really impressive
talk about a guy feeling it seeing the
ball well
his second of the year the three-run
lead kyle ryan the left-hander has been
doing this a long time and this would be
the first save of his pro career
on the ground picked up by kipnis that
is the second out
a run scores it's five to three that'll
be charged to kimbrell
two down five three cubs how big does
contreras homer in the eighth inning
look now against franco
play him to pull in the outfield
a drive into center field that's a base
hit a solid single for
michael franco coming in to score is
monday and now it is a five to four ball
game how ryan is doing right here is
that he's hoping that nick heath is
gonna assume well he's not gonna throw
over here a fourth time and just take
off on first movement and he knows that
he's a rookie there he goes huge jump
here's the throw and it goes into center
and he's going to make third
and it's one-on-one on starling
now wilson might have been better off
not making that throw he had a huge jump
pretty impressive with the lefty on the
mound now the tying run is 90 feet away
so the royals send nick heath
and he had second base stolen by a mile
royals are down to their last strike
nice play brian throw to first cubs win
that ball was hit
like a rocket and bryant made it look
easy and the cubs sweep the two-game
series and the five-game home stand wow
deep breath exhale